The Midnight Spoil: Civil War.
Hey! Hey, hey, hey, hey!
Hey, hey, hey, hey!
Hey, hey, hey! Captain America:
Civil War comes out today,
and it's (bleep) great.
It's so good.
And the Spider-Man... and the
Spider-Man integration is great
and Ant-Man's great in it
and there's stuff in there
that will surprise you
and it's really fun
and it's delightful after the...
coming off the intense romantic
thriller of Batman v Superman.
So, uh, this is the...
this is the sequel
to the, uh, less exciting
Captain America: Flame War,
where Cap just, uh, went
on Iron Man's YouTube page
and kept saying "fake" and "gay"
on all his videos.
Uh, so, in honor of
the summer's first blockbuster,
where your favorite Marvel
superheroes beat the (bleep) out
of each other, I'm gonna ask you
to give me as many spoilers
for Civil War as you can
in 60 seconds.
And begin. Marcella.
Black Panther has to use
the Underground Railroad.
-Mmm.
-Points.
Jesse.
Uh, at the premiere, Abe Lincoln
gets killed in the theater.
All right, points. Damien.
Black Panther becomes
three-fifths of an Avenger.
Oh, (bleep). Points. Marcella.
Hawkeye realizes he's useless
and goes
to grab everyone Starbucks.
Yeah, points.
Yeah, but... but with an arrow.
He fires an arrow that's got
the chip in it that just pays
-for all the drinks and then
brings it back around. -Yeah.
-Card reader.
-Jesse.
Hawkeye will be played
by Forest Whitaker,
and they're gonna change
his name to Lazy Eye.
All right.
Oh, no. Oh, no.